this is a production of cornell
university
so thank you thank you sandy i couldn't
have
presented my work better than sandy did
really i need to write it so i know how
to describe it in the future
and it's very
special for me to to be here and have
sandy
also introducing me it's been
six years since i left it's really nice
to come
visit here i've been telling to people
that when you live here you forget a
little how how pretty it is here how
beautiful because you get used to it too
much
but um
when you come visit here you'll suddenly
see it wow it's so uh
it's so pretty and
also it's i think the first time i'm
giving a talk
um
in front of real people in many many
years so i need to i'm a little nervous
so it's been really like going back in
time but just the gray hair
unfortunately doesn't go back
yeah
and
so
[Laughter]
thanks
so yeah so i left here at 2016
and i moved to
this okay to lake alfred
in florida this is a
research station of the university of
florida that focuses on citrus research
and also it was a big change moving from
arabidopsis i don't know if you can see
this little thing here
into studying uh citrus trees
there was in one very
in one zoo meeting when i was spacing
out and i was bored i calculated that
just on the top part you can
fit in
1500 arabidopsis
plants so it's been
a very big uh different kind of research
so everything was very different also
and also working with the trees it's a
different
level of complexity it's extremely slow
but it's been good it's been very very
good it's been i was just telling gary
we talked about it's nice to step out of
your comfort zone
sometimes
and also
the reality has many more sunny days
than the bubble
so that was also
a very
nice thing
i hope you can hear it
so in my lab like sandy said we are
we
we focus on
pathogens that are phloem localized in
citrus and we have two
favorite pathogens one is the citrus
tristasa virus and the other is the
candidatus liberibacter asciaticus which
is a bacteria
and for both of them we are looking at
the plant host and also the insect host
and we're trying to study
uh the interaction uh between the
pathogen and the hosts but today i'll
just focus on one part on the phloem
association between candidatus liberia
bacteria sciaticus and the citrus
so candidates slippery bacteroaciaticus
which i will call silas from now on is
the causal agent of
citrus greening or citrus
huanglong bean which i will call agel b
so silas is the pathogen it's the
bacteria and age will be is the disease
i'm sure you heard a lot about this
disease from michelle
um
it is a very very devastating disease
in florida
and i'll show you just how much so this
is from a very recent
um
news article that shows the production
of oranges so florida used to produce
between 200 to 250 million boxes per
year and today it's less than 50 so the
industry really
went down
by about 85
so it's a huge huge
blow to the citrus industry in florida
and grapefruit is the same thing in just
a few numbers
in the last five years each year florida
is losing a billion
one billion dollars
each year five thousand people lose
their jobs so if you think about these
10 15 years that the disease went on
it's a huge numb
huge number of people that
lost their jobs in this industry the
number of growers really
shrunk and there is no cures to the
disease
so the pathogen
silas is a gram negative bacteria it's
intracellular so
unlike most of the bacteria that
we are studying it's
inside another cell and it's not
culturable which makes sense because it
needs to be in a host cell
and also it's flowing limited which is
also making studying this disease
more complicated because the phloem is a
very narrow tissue inside the tree and
it's very hard to get to this tissue
very hard to isolate this tissue
so this
is definitely not an easy
disease to study and unfortunately
we know very little about the mechanism
of the disease what what is causing was
and how the disease is progressing
and what we do know is that after the
tree
will get infected by the um
by the bacteria and that bacteria is
transmitted by an insect by a sealed
and
slowly slowly you will see a decline
in the tree
the trees
the roots are dying the canopy starts to
die and it's a slow process that takes
a few years until
eventually the tree
will die
but throughout this whole process it
will not produce
the regular yield that the growers
need to get
in terms of what we see that is
happening in the tree after the bacteria
enters we see that there is flagging of
the phloem
there is accumulation of calories inside
the phloem
there is induction of the defense
response of the tree there is hormones
in balance in the tree and there's an
induction of the reactive oxygen
species
so the way i organize this talk and i'll
present our work
i did it in a way that we're going from
the
field
going down to the physiology to the
cellular and then some molecular level
studies and
all of this work was important for us to
understand more and more about how the
disease progresses and what's the
mechanism of the disease
so i'll start with the
field uh work and this work we did in
collaboration with another lab
with tripty vaccines
and here what we and wanted to
understand this was really a very
applied project it was
very much like growers in mind to help
the growers
and what we wanted to see is which
parameters are important for the disease
so
from
the grower perspective
uh severe disease is when you don't have
a lot of fruit and a mild disease is
when you have a lot of fruit but to
measure
every time the yield the fruit yield is
very very
difficult and almost impossible so we
were looking for something else that we
can see in the tree that can tell the
growers this tree is very sick or this
tree is lastic because it's just like
with kovid you know we can all get the
pathogen but some of us
will be very severely ill but others
will not feel anything and this is also
true
for the trees they're not reacting in
the same way
and so if we go with this kind of human
diseasing what we are looking at is to
find something like when we measure the
temperature that we can give the growers
something easy to measure the
temperature of the tree and that will
tell him this tree is
very sick or this tree is not very sick
so it was a long project with a lot of
factors and i won't go
over everything
what we wanted to see is what is
what correlates with the yield
eventually and we found three
factors that are correlated with the
yield so the first one was the canopy
volume
so um
if you have more canopy
you're going to produce
more fruits you're you're healthier
the light interception uh which is
how much light is uh intercepted
absorbed
by
the tree
so
if you have a more light absorbed it
means your canopy
canopies is denser and you will produce
more fruits and the last one that was
correlated was the fruit detachment
force so
um how strong the fruit is connected to
the tree if it's
if it's harder to pull off it's if it's
connected stronger
then the tree gives more yield
the tree is healthier
but maybe the most interesting thing for
the rest of the talk is that we when we
looked at the city values and the
bacterial population we didn't see any
uh correlation with the yield so it
didn't matter if the bacteria was higher
or lower it didn't affect how much yield
the tree is going to give
and i'm showing here in
this is another example so this is three
field trials that we did
with different sweet orange varieties
different ages and we
divided the trees according to the
slight interception so if
there is less than
90 interception or if more than 10
percent of the light can go through
that means that the canopy is not very
dense you have those little holes in the
canopy and we call these ones a
severe tree
but if the canopy
takes more than 90 percent of the light
we call this just mild so the canopy is
denser
and when we took all these trees in
these different trials and we separated
them we saw that this works really well
and this is something that we really are
now trying to push
for growers because you're just all you
need to do is measure the light on top
of the canopy and then below you can see
how much light is absorbed and it really
divided very nicely
the trees according to the yield so in
all the examples
the mild ones which absorbed more more
light had
about double
the yield compared to the one that
absorbed less slides
but again here when we looked at the
city values and the bacterial population
there was just no difference that we can
see between the ones that produce twice
the yield or half the yield
in this first example even there's twice
the amount of bacteria and you get more
yield so that really was
the most maybe the most interesting for
us in this
study and so we were asking maybe it's
not directly the pathogen
that is causing the disease and maybe
it's more about the plant response that
is involved in the disease progression
okay so the next
thing that we did we were thinking
what what can be
something that
can cause the disease that's related to
the plant response and like i told you
before um one thing that was known that
there is accumulation of calories in the
phloem of these
trees and so we did some
another project when we wanted to see if
maybe the accumulation of calories is
related to plugging the phloem and
decreasing the sugar transport in those
trees
so callows
is a helical polymer of beta13 glucan
and the idea with calories is that it
forms this sugar that's very soft it's
like gelatinous
and when you have beta 1 4 connection
you'll get cellulose cellulose is very
very steep it's almost
impossible to break cellulose people
were trying a lot with all these
biofuels uh things but it's very very
difficult
and but
the better one three
with better one three connections are
much easier to break and the plant is
using the cellulose when it needs
something to be
stable and forever
but we'll choose always colors if
something needs to be temporary but you
can deposit and then break it later
so it's not surprising that
when it comes to
blocking the flowing pores or the
plasmodesmata one of the most important
mechanisms is this deposition of
calories
so in the phloem and just a quick
reminder flowing is built from the sieve
tube elements
and the sieve tube elements
are almost there there's very little
inside which allows the flow but what is
really limiting the flow of the
molecules like and sugars and hormones
and nutrients
is the sieve plate with the sieve pores
and also the
sieve tube elements are connected to
companion cells between with
plasmodesmata with regular plasmodesmata
and both the plasmodesmata here and the
sieve pores
are regulated by carlos deposition so
calories when it's deposited it blocks
the connection and limits the movement
so you can see this is a very simple
diagram of the plasmodesmata and without
callows you will have
an open pore and things like um
like the sugars or sometimes viruses and
other pathogens will be able to move
from one cell to the other but when you
have colors deposited it will block
the pore and will stop the movement
and another thing that's important is
that when you look at these disease
symptoms it'll be symptoms you see a lot
of things that sort of suggest that
there's a problem with the sugar
transport because the leaves they
develop this
green
um
greenish um
[Music]
symptom that we call blotchy mottled
but when you stain and you you see that
they also accumulate a lot of starch
which always tells you that there's a
problem with the transport also the
fruits are
bitter they're asymmetrical and they are
green so there's a lot of
signs that maybe something is wrong with
the sugar translocation
also when you are taking an healthy
plant and you are taking off the floor
and if you just griddle the floor out
the symptoms that you're getting are
similar to what you have with a
sick hlb tree
so we sort of like put everything
together and we um
were asking maybe this callous
accumulation
uh
is uh slowing down the sugar transport
and
maybe this is one mechanism of this
disease
so we developed we wanted to do
something with big data and we developed
this method to and
to get to the phloem and stain with
aniline blue and then we developed
this macro this little program that
gets rid of a lot of the background like
you can see on the side of the picture
here
and just
identifies the colors flags and then
the program just automatically do all
the measurements and we can really have
a big amount of data
i'll just mention now because it's good
to talk about ai i don't know how it is
in cornell but in florida they're going
completely nuts about it
and that we started to use ai
and to
to identify those carlos flags and it's
really is better i mean it is a much
better way to do things we get
a much higher
sensitivity
with those
techniques and we are now
detecting i think a lot of these carlos
plugs so we have a very good
level
of data
so when we look at the phloem in a
healthy tree and then in
age will be infected tree you can see
these confocal images here there's no
it's not hard to see that it gets
completely
plugged and there's a huge difference so
the plant is responding very strongly
and
there's a lot of calories that is
accumulated inside the floor
so now the other part is the sugar
translocation so here we use this nice
setup so we we
closed
one leaf inside this sealed box and then
we used a
radio-labeled c14
so if we inject into this box the
radioactive
b-carbonite where
the carbon is labeled with citric acid
we will get inside this box now the co2
gas
and now this gas the co2 will be
absorbed by the leaf
and
the plant will make the sugars and they
will start to
be transported
inside the phloem but the nice thing is
that they are now
radio labeled so if we put a detector
we can see exactly when they reach to
this point and with another detector we
can see how when they reach this point
and we know the distance between those
points we can measure the speed of the
sugar transport inside the tree and the
beauty of this
system is that it's completely
non-invasive and that's really
very important when you're working with
phloem
everything you do changes things but
here we're not we're not touching
anything basically we're not doing
anything that
damages the plant or change the plant
so we did this kind of big experiment we
looked at different a lot of sites and a
lot of
measurements but in general
we were looking at the translocation
speed the colors and
on the
city value and the bacteria number
in those trees
so this is the
carlos accumulation so we did this
experiment on two different root stocks
it's sweet orange on two different root
stocks
one is cleopatra and the other x
639
there was accumulation of calories in
both but it was much higher in the x 639
when we looked at the translocation
speed we didn't see a difference when uh
in the cleopatra but in the x-639 with
this big callows change there was a
strong reduction in the translocation
speed
also we looked at the export
of the sugars from the leaf and also it
was there was no difference in
the cleopatra but a big difference in
the x
six
639
so we see here that the rootstock had
also an effect on this translocation
speed which is interesting another thing
that the speeds that we were
seeing are very
very slow
and and it's a
more typical for the g for the
gymnosperms
so citrus might be this kind of special
case where
it's not a gymnosperm but it is an
evergreen so maybe evergreens are
for some reason that we don't know they
don't
want a high
speed of translocation
but for us the more important thing was
to see if there's any connection between
those things and when we
uh put it together we see that there is
a statistical uh
significant connection between the kalos
and the phlearn translocation so with
more calories you are reducing the
translocation speed in the flow
and we could even
calculate that every calorie deposit
reduce the speed by 0.04
centimeter per hour and we can even
model it with a regression model and
also put in the city values so the
bacteria
number
and
you we could see that
with more infectivity higher bacteria
means that there's more calories that is
deposited
and
it reduces
the translocation speed so here we have
um
a nice
mechanism to suggest for this disease
that the bacteria comes in
it causes calories to accumulate in the
phloem and this results in slower
translocation speed
in the phloem
and this will slowly slowly
kill the plants because
everything
will not get the amount of energy and
sugar that it needs to get
just a second my throat is dry
okay
so then the next level that we looked at
is the cell
biology and this is my favorite
thing
and and here we wanted to see okay so
what is happening in the flow and we
want to understand a little about the
interaction between the bacteria and
so unfortunately we cannot label uh the
class with any gfp
and we can't use the confocal which is
the easiest and
my favorite thing
and but
with this bacteria we had to use the tem
which is much more
difficult but it worked well
we can see the bacteria and we can label
it with an antibody here it's an
antibody against the outer membrane
protein of the bacteria
and you can see that the bacteria has
different
shapes different structures it can be
s means a spherical so a round structure
it can be a tubular like like a hot dog
or it can be what we call flex which is
this half
round half elongated structure that we
think
it's this kind of
intermediate structure so it seems like
this bacteria can change and it can move
between the different
morphologies
and another thing just to
and show you how the phloem side looks
under the electron microscope so on the
right side you can see
the sieve plate
cw that's the cell wall
the pp can be two things it's the
flowing pore but it's also
the fluorine proteins you see this dark
material inside the pore
and then the calories is here so ca is
the calories and that's the calories
that is deposited and we always see some
level of colors in the flowing pores but
you can really see
to get this kind of
image of
how more colors will be blocking
the transport between a one sieve
element to the other sieve element
and
so we were
we wanted to look at the bacteria inside
the floor and when we thought that the
best way will be to look at
the sink tissues because
we assume that the bacteria will go with
the flow and flow
so we were testing different
sink
tissues and i'll just show you two that
we looked at
one is the flush the new leaves and the
other is
the seed coat so in the fruit so both
are
zinc tissues
and again we wanted to see the bacteria
inside the cells and also very
interesting for us it's how the bacteria
move from one sieve element to the other
one
so i'll start with the leaves the young
leaves
so here you have
the tem images and
this this is the plate here
you can see the colors and and then you
can see
the open space that is available
in the healthy one most of it is open
then on the center on the right one
it's both infected
either non-symptomatic or symptomatic
with the non-symptomatic you have an
example here one for it's open and one
for it's closed and on the symptomatic
it's an example for something that's
completely plugged and
there's nothing uh there's no pore
there's no opening left in these borders
huge accumulation of the colors but of
course everything was came
there was a lot of diversity between
things but if we look when we look at a
lot of the pictures and we
calculate everything so what we're
calculating here on the right is the
poor opening so what's the size of the
open port the available
uh
open
uh
opening in the poor
so we can see that there's
um
the pores in the
infected tree in the sick trees are more
closed there's always more calories that
is closing the pores compared to the
healthy ones and when we look at the
genes that are involved in
phloem
plugging so that's
the
the cal
er the cal s that's the calor synthase
that's the genes that are
producing colors that are depositing
colors
and the pp2 is the fluorine protein
that's also
involved in
poor plugging with the flowing protein
so
in general all of them are upregulated
some more than the others but there's a
general upregulation of all these genes
that
makes sense but here was another
surprise that we didn't see any bacteria
inside these cells so we see the
plugging we see the phloem getting
plugged by
by the colors but we don't see bacteria
and we were looking and looking and
there was very very little bacteria
this is in this table you can see a two
year study that we did and we looked at
a lot of sieve elements
and the
percentage of sieve elements that
contained bacteria it ranged from 0 to
13. and so let's say 10
or maybe it's probably more because i
don't think with the tm we get
everything
but for sure there's very little uh
bacteria much less than we expected and
most of the sieve elements
they are getting plugged but without
having the bacteria inside
then we went to the seed coats and here
we saw
almost you can say the mirror image the
opposite image so
tons of bacteria in every section that
we looked at there was never a seed coat
that wasn't full of bacteria so it was
always always have
tons of bacteria inside but if you can
see the pores especially on the right
pictures
you can see that there's just zero
colors here there's nothing it's
completely open and this is at a level
that you don't usually see you never see
plasmodesmata or
flowing poor with
zero colors with no colors at all
so that was um interesting and we were
asking
what's the reason so it can be something
about the seed coats maybe the plant
does not deposit colors in the seed
coats because it wants to
preserve the phloem running and the
offspring
or it can be something that the bacteria
is maybe the bacteria is actually
breaking the colors so
we compared it now to healthy seed coats
which is not an easy thing to do in
florida
good luck finding a healthy
fruit
but we were lucky because there was
another experiment that was running
where we work that
grew
trees under
protection
protecting protected structures so we
can really build
this experiment
so now when we look at the healthy seed
coats we see that there's always a
certain level of calories a certain
level of
normal clogging in the phloem
but when you have the bacteria inside
when you have it infected then it's
completely open there's no callows at
all and we look again at a lot of
pictures we measure the poor opening
and we see this
strange situation that
actually when the bacteria is present
there's no
there's no calories at all then we
looked at the
gene
regulation
and again at the calocintes and the
flowing proteins and here everything
goes down very dramatically so
all of those color synthesis and also
the pp2 they are going down when you
have
the bacteria inside so it's almost the
opposite
of what we thought is happening
with the bacteria
and one nice thing was
that with this high level of bacteria we
can see also the bacteria crossing
this the flowing pores
and you can really see how there is this
perfect fit between
the bacteria and the pores so
you can understand why the bacteria has
to break all the calories that will be
in the pores otherwise there is no way
that the bacteria can move through
you can see sometimes it takes this
little turn and
really fit inside the pore
very nicely
but one thing you can see that also
was interesting we were thinking about
those helical structures that are
definitely too big to move uh through
the flowing pores but
we saw a lot of the situations when
when these guys came into the poor they
actually were able to change their
structure
and then fit right into the pore
and fit inside and then move to the
other side so there's a lot of
those bacteria are not passive at all
and they bind to the port
and they are able to target the poor and
also somehow
move through
we can also we also saw that there's a
lot of
binding to the membrane right next to
the flowing pores and we think that's
part of the targeting
of the bacteria to the pores to enable
the movement so speaking about destiny
or something like this you know i i did
all this
virus movement work with sandy
i went to florida i changed to citrus i
changed to bacteria
but again i'm dealing with opening the
pores targeting the plasma membrane and
moving through from one cell to the
other so there's no escape
and again i'm looking we're looking for
a movement protein here that the
bacteria is using
to move from one cell to the other so
i'm just stuck in this topic
there's no way out
we also looked at the reactive
oxygen species and we saw the same thing
in the leaves
there's a strong
induction of the reactive oxidant
species but remember there's not a lot
of bacteria here
and this is
the seed coats where we isolated the
vasculature and we see that we see the
opposite thing there is a
decrease in the
accumulation of
the reactive oxygen species and also in
the gene that is producing those
reactive roses
just to be sure that it's not something
that's specific to the seed coat that
it's a general thing we went back to the
leaves but now here
we divided the cells the sieve elements
to those that have the bacteria which
were the very small part and the cells
that
don't have the bacteria that we don't
see any bacteria inside and when we look
at those flowing pores
in the ones that don't have the bacteria
in the leaf
we see that there's plugging you can see
this in the pictures
in the bottom side
of the
of the slide
but where you have the bacteria inside
when we see the bacteria inside suddenly
the pores are much more open so it's the
same thing that the bacteria is doing
also in the leaves but
the
major effect
is the effect of the
bottom part because most cells just
don't have the bacteria inside
so now we are suggesting a different
sort of scenario here
where we have
the healthy cells
and they will have we can call it this
physiological level of calories
physiological level of reactive oxygen
species of salicylic acid
but then in the infected tree we have
two scenarios we have the cells that
don't have the bacteria inside and in
these cells the plant is responding very
strongly and accumulates the calories in
the pores
accumulates the reactive oxygen species
induces this the salicylic acid
but in the cells that have the bacteria
actually there will be
attenuation of the defense response the
bacteria really inhibits the plant
response
and so there's a very low level of
reactive oxygen species and the pores
are open and the bacteria can move a
cell to cell
and the last part will be the molecular
part which is very difficult with citrus
you know it's uh
it's not easy to do molecular work when
we are trying to
let's say transform a tree
it will take years until we can use it
for anything
so the student which did it already left
the money is already gone the project
already changed and we sometimes we have
to
think hard what we wanted to do with
this when we planned it in the beginning
but
still we can do some molecular level the
big problem is the genetics it's really
we are working with very little genetics
but
what we did here we wanted to understand
okay so now we have a good system we can
learn a little about
what's happening the interaction between
the bacteria
and the fluence so we developed this
method that we can take the seeds and we
can dissect
just the vasculature out so this is the
vasculature that's connected
to the plant and then it feeds into the
seed
and so this really
gives us a good system because
the big limitations for this were always
that there's not a lot of bacteria in
the leaves and it's very hard to
get
clean vasculature and here we are sort
of killing two birds at once and we get
only the vasculature with tons of silas
inside and we are doing now a lot of
genomics and proteomics and protein
interactions
and so we are in the stage where we
we have all these big lists that we need
to
understand what they mean
and
but we are really getting good stuff we
see a lot of
proteins going up a lot of defense
related protein a lot of things that are
related to calories
we see a lot of antimicrobial
peptides going up so we have a lot to to
work with but i'll just show you now one
example
and so like i said genetics it's very
difficult but
we are very lucky for
three people
working with citrus because we do have
one system that only takes a year or two
which is amazing
and
and that's using the citrus tristasa
virus so you you you can do virus
induced gene silencing with the citrus
to stasa virus
and the nice thing with these
is that you can see here they silence
the pds and when i say they it's the
build
bill dawson lab that
worked in our center
and
the the really lucky thing is that also
citrus just as a virus is phloem
localized so for agent b research it's
really lucky situation that we can do
some gene silencing and it's
specifically in the flow
so this is a good system and i'm going
to show one example but unfortunately
i'm not going i can't say the name of
the specific gene because we applied for
a patent with this
so i have to keep it quiet but it's
something that i worked on before if you
will
look at my list of publications you you
won't have a lot of
candidates to choose from so it's one of
them
and i call it callus regulator so with
this uh citrus to stasa system we were
able to down regulate the expression of
this gene
and we saw that it worked very nicely to
really decrease the expression of
calories since the seven and the pp2 and
there was less calories so what we
wanted to do here is to reduce the
plugging to to open the veins let the
sugar flow
better
and with these plants there was also
when we looked at the
developments of development of the
disease symptoms there was a delay in
the onset of the symptoms we only saw
symptoms
in about half of the trees and
the symptoms level was a much
lower so they weren't very severe
but maybe
sort of like the interesting thing here
is that
what we're doing here reducing the
calocintes and we're reducing the pp2 is
just like what i showed you
a few minutes ago that the bacteria is
doing so
we are actually mimicking
what the pathogen is doing here so in a
certain way we are helping the bacteria
or at least mimicking
the bacteria action here but this gives
us
less
symptoms in the tree so it's in
really cool
situations so this is the last slide
where i'll try to put everything
together
so what we are thinking now that we have
the phloem
at one point the bacteria will enter the
form
and then the phloem will very quickly
induce a defense response to block the
bacteria eventually probably kill the
cell and get rid of the bacteria by
inducing
the calories in the flowing pores and
also inducing the reactive oxygen
species but unfortunately this
defense response it's not effective at
all because the bacteria comes
with some mechanism
to
break down the calories or inhibits the
the the position of calories and to down
regulate the reactive oxygen species so
this defense response
really does not it's not able to block
the bacteria the bacteria has what it
needs to
to counteract this defense and not only
is it not efficient
it's also turned on in a lot of sieve
elements that don't have any bacteria at
all
and maybe that's even the worst
situation because here
in those cells which are the majority of
the cells you are blocking the sugar
transport and then slowly slowly
the tree just declines declines declines
and eventually
the tree dies
so it's this kind of situation that
definitely
not working for the tree it's very
inefficient
for the tree side
and now what we are trying to so this is
sort of like where we are now in terms
of
describing the situation and what we are
trying to do now is
use this
model to think of ways that we can
inhibit the disease progression so we're
thinking of two ways one of them will be
to
understand how the bacteria
inhibits this defense response how the
bacteria opens the pores and reduce the
roses and if we will understand it and
we will be able to somehow block it
then
the plant defense response will become
much more efficient and then the plant
can really crash and kill hopefully the
bacteria but
there's also another way like i showed
you
and so another if we call this the the
aggressive way the the
here we are trying to kill the bacteria
we can also do something that's not
it's more nice to the bacteria
non-confrontative way and we can also
try
to just
abolish or reduce the defense response
of the plan the plant responds to the
bacteria and what we are seeing that
maybe it won't be perfect there's other
things that's probably going on but we
are able
also to reduce the
disease symptoms if we will make the
plant fight a little less and let the
bacteria live
so that's it that's what i have so
thanks
everybody for listening
and these are the people from the lab
that
um
some of them are involved in this work
and
we also had close collaborations with
bill dawson now it's the el montar lab
with christopher vincent and assist i
didn't write everybody here we're also
working
with wenberman with bob turton here
and the funding first came from the
from uf early career seed grant and then
later from the usda
and thank you very much for listening
so gillian asked me to emcee the
questions what we'll do is take
questions from the room first
and then we'll move to questions from
zoom so
folks in zoom land uh go ahead and type
your questions into the chat or
um
or raise your hand and i will try and
figure out
how to find you let me escape here so
questions here i want you to just hand a
little bit
hi i enjoyed that a lot thanks a couple
of quick questions first of all you had
some differences in your cultivars of
citrus and i assume they're all they're
all clonal whether any given variety is
a clone identical okay so was there any
difference that could be exploited in
the in the genetics of the citrus
varieties
yeah we don't know
um
that yet but we do see i didn't put it
here and i was thinking if i should put
or not but i wanted to make it simple
we do see that there's some we don't
have any resistant varieties but we do
have tolerant varieties
and in the tolerant varieties of
tolerance it means that the pathogen is
still there but we still get good yield
the
the symptoms are not showing so much
and we looked at
a sugar bell we looked at
a mexican lime
and also there's a
one example
i mean the most advanced thing
is that they were able to express the
npr one
so that's a transgenic plan that also is
tolerant and in all the three of those
we see less calories
we don't know the genetic details but
with all of those
there is less calories
in the flour so
we
[Music]
we are now also looking at the
translocation speed but we didn't do it
yet
but there must be something
in those tolerance that they react
less and i think that's uh
um
it maybe it's even
beyond
these
phloem things i think
a lot of the times and
when the plant reacts too much it's it's
actually not good it's just like coffee
seems like a classic example of
tolerance rather than resistance yeah it
is tolerance i think i'm just curious if
you have insight in if you could
limit that host response the callous uh
you know closing up of those pores
uh
would that in the absence of the uh
bacterium
have a negative effect on
the old physiology of oranges or
yeah so
we always see some
calories and
and
but usually
um
we are
usually calories accumulates through
large amounts in response to some stress
that's usually the case that's where you
see the
massive things
but yeah it's not as simple as as i
showed here for sure because
without callows there won't be any
development of civ elements even because
carlos deposition is even part of the
the
how the pores are made
so it is more complicated than this
diagram for sure yeah we
we will need to find the right
it's a matter of
where and how yeah it's not
a yes or no black and white thing
well
the all of those bacteria in the
fruit um are they multiplying in the
fruit or do you think some of them are
actually being transported
moving along the floor transport pathway
and arriving
and we think
oh okay so bob was asking why why do we
see
so much bacteria in the fruit is it
because the bacteria gets there and
multiply or because it keeps coming in
so i would say that mostly it's the
second that they keep coming in because
you know the fruit of citrus it's like
almost a year of development it's like
eight months
it's a long long time that the flames
just go in and in and so
i don't think there's really
it's it's really a model thing i don't
think it's important for the disease or
anything but it's just a consequence of
the situation that
it just keeps coming in for month and
month and month but we do see sometimes
but i i cannot
say that
it's proving anything but we do see if
i'll go back
and we do see
a lot of times that it looks like
they're also dividing we see those
structures that looks like dividing
bacteria and we see that a lot so
maybe a combination of both there's not
so many bacteria in the roots
but
that would also be an end point for
transport so
it's a little curious there that why you
don't find a big buildup of factory
ridge yeah yeah
yeah we looked at we looked at the roots
and it's like this kind of in between
there's more
than the leaves but it's not like
um
it's not like
this those those fruits
i know maybe the fruit is just a much
stronger sink compared to the roots
just like one more from the room clear
and then we'll move to the
zoom questions so
you talk about detection and difficulty
detection so can you leverage this c
code
or fruit are they already doing that for
improving detection yeah we're trying to
tell people if you want to do pcr
go for the
seed coats it's the problem with seed
coat is that you have to
dissect if you just take the whole seed
it's very hard to do pcrs there's a lot
of dirty materials there you have to
um
first
get rid you have there's an extra step
that you have to do so that's a little
problematic but we're trying we're
telling
people that it's not very successful the
other question was does are these
findings applied into the other libero
factors
so the pathogenic
dinner
what sorry did the finding with the
calories does anything similar we found
with the other liberal vector
so claire was asking if with other
liberty back there we are also seeing
the colors accumulation
so
yeah i think
i think so i'm certain about other
intracellular
pathogens like the phytoplasma
for sure
with utterly very bacter i
i think so but i can't say that i have
100
like
clear thing in my head if i saw
that they were
looking at it but the phytoplasma also
caused this
okay i think we have time to do these
two questions in the chat i'll ask them
together and you can just answer them
together okay from madeline loss what is
limiting the use of young citrus plants
for the study of sea loss interactions
in flesh
uh and then marina man asked um
can you elaborate a bit more on how you
distinguish class using tm how can you
tell it's not some other
endophytic bacterium yeah so for the
first question i mean for the flush we
do use
younger
trees the the problem became when we
needed the fruits so
that you have to use older trees but
yeah when we are doing experiments when
all we want to do is look at the
young leaves we can grow them in the
greenhouse and they are like this big
and that's
that's enough for us
about the second question um
so
like what we're using is uh
this antibody against the outer membrane
protein and we are labeling the bacteria
but like you saw we don't do it
in every experiment that we're doing
because we are
it's just will be too complicated we
sort of
do a few examples we're using the
antibody and then in the other
experiment we didn't use it so i will
say that i can't be hundred percent sure
but
we can be 100 sure that this is
the bacteria that cause
the citrus greening disease because we
see it only
when the
uh when the when the trees are infected
we never see any bacteria in the phloem
in healthy trees
it could be a mixture maybe there's more
than
one specific bacteria i i don't um
i mean i can't rule that out and but for
us we just uh
what we care about is that this is the
bacteria that is associated with the
disease but maybe there's a mix there
okay uh let's uh please join me in
thanking and meet again for re-talking
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu